the hunt is on for a wild coyote on the
loose in downtown Chicago authorities
caught one animal last night after two
reported attacks but one is still on the
run
the city hasn't had to deal with
something like this in three decades
in one instance two athletes at DePaul
University said they kicked the coyote
away after it attacked the six year old
boy on Wednesday that very same day
another man showed up at the hospital
saying he had been attacked by a coyote
experts say the animals are in the city
searching for food because of the very
cold weather you know one of the Coyotes
in a city there I keep hearing they're
looking for that limping one yeah don't
do the one that you just saw in the
video there the limping coyote again we
used to get him out of the suburbs now
and then but but happen in the city is
yeah cold weather in Chicago is no
surprise so something else well so the
animal care of Chicago says that coyotes
have been in the city actually for
decades and for generations but this is
the first time that they've seen these
attacks in three - Wow
30 years
you